preis ok schüssen hatte ich damit jetzt
unten mit dem schwert brauchst du dafür
drei freunde herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren runde von minecraft
galaxy zusammen mit dem guten alten
kräfte scheinbar weg dementsprechend
kollekten einfach mal auf den server ja
ich bin nicht mehr einfach weggelaufen
der stirn zu ich weiß es nicht einfach
mal stimmt einfach als die wahrheit ist
ahmed ja was ist ein plan
mein plan ist mir ein bisschen wasser zu
holen denn ich brauche was für mein
dynamo denn ich werde heute ganz sicher
halte hier sticht beruht alter ego war
er erst jetzt langsam wenn du ne hamburg
bist du dann kriege ich gute eine
schnelle weise nächste respekt stelle
bekommen so machen durch ich mach das
mal ein bisschen holz hier hummels
palmert und dann mache ich einfach mein
haus ein bisschen schöner und dann ich
weiß nie was in mit dem pulver reiser
kannst du doch einfach die ärzte die es
gibt
in pulver umwandeln kannst das pulver
irgendwie lang ist die doppelte an
seinen ärzten raus oder genauso so
funktioniert das ganze ich habe den
allerdings nicht für diesen zweck jetzt
gebaut sondern um mir relativ viel
papier herzustellen weil dieses ganze
zuckerrohr fahren
das ist alles ein bisschen nervig und
das dann wieder anzubauen man kann
einfach holz nehmen und das dort in wood
ships umwandeln
das muss jetzt bin ich auf jeden fall
mal gespannt ob das jetzt hier
funktioniert wie ich mir das vorgestellt
habe und mein vorsicht mai hat sich
bewegt nicht mal ein anderes netz das
brauch ich weiß nicht was mit ihm los
ich habe auch so ein bisschen angst sein
ja das wird ja manchmal die leute legen
immer alles gleich was man sagt auf die
weiter angst ist mein drache hier
irgendwie sports und weißt du den
feuerdrachen verbrennt im feuer
das war echt nicht sogar hatte ich so
meine immunität den hoffentlich das war
echt nice so habe ich auch wenn ich
heuer fallen dann verbrennt das feuer
und nichtig aber so ein bisschen pulver
reiser vor ich hab keine ahnung dieser
reise du musst du mir mal zeigen
die sägerei sein kann bewegende sei aber
bei mir nehmen anhausen auch schon 23
du lieber gar keinen respekt davor die
kurse an dem thema die einen der max hat
ja auch ein
und ich sitze hier mit einer fledermaus
eine runde mitleid
ja aber ich kann als fehler muss unter
meine kisten runter klettern und das
mache ich platt ein bisschen rom setzte
jetzt aber mal ein bisschen holz hin
auch das team dynamo noch irgendwelche
sachen ok generated solutions team
einfach mal die kohle raus dann kann ich
quasi sind robbie kraft stuhl wieder
abbauen
ich glaube schon aber jetzt jetzt kommt
auf jeden fall mal ein bisschen steam an
und jetzt wird das auch verarbeiten das
ganze denn bitte wie du das ganze passt
mit dem steam dynamo der braucht ein
bisschen wasser oder das ist das doch
nicht das was ich das nicht holen dachte
weil das bei mega park wasser das wir
ich weiß nicht was mega projekt noch je
ich kenne das megaprojekt ja ich hab's
erfolg weil da war es halt so dass man
ja wie was da eigentlich
wir hatten halt auch so eine
modifikation und man musste das ganze
halt irgendwie
bauern über generatoren oder
nuklearenergie oder windenergie
ich habe mich für solarenergie
entschieden letztendlich irgendwie du
ganz gute entscheidung
allerdings war das ganze sehr sehr
aufwändig also um so ein solarpanel das
war nach solarpanels halt einfach dass
wir mit dass er quasi betrieben hast um
das nachher zu bauen
brauchst du dann locker nochmal
irgendwie 45 folgen um einen sonderteil
zu bauen
und du braucht es acht von diesen teilen
und das kann es ja irgendwie zu bauen
und so das war ein mega zeitaufwendig
deswegen war das megaprojekt am ende
quasi nur noch kräften und ich hoffe
dass das hier anders ist weil du hast
zum beispiel jetzt schon relativ schnell
das ganze hinbekommen ja aber es gibt ja
sogar weiter aufbaut was mich mal
interessieren würde vor allem bei den
zuschauern
wer denn alles noch dass das mega
projekt sozusagen miterlebt hat oder wer
da wer die zeit zb verpasst hat das
würde mich echt mal interessieren
schreib deine augen interessant kleinen
zuschauern also gerade beide ein weil
bei dir ist es ja so du machst du jetzt
noch nicht sagt 45 10.000 jahren videos
oder heißt dieser wann machst video ich
ich ich hab seit ich mache schon seit
anderthalb jahren nur anderthalb jahren
aber jetzt nicht zur seite 5 6000 jahren
das war schon so lange dass jene bist
dass man sich denn überhaupt sagen du
bist weiß ich auch
ja ja genau befestigt auf jeden fall
schreibt einfach in die kommentare
das wird mich auf jeden fall echt mal
interessieren während ich jetzt mal
jedoch so ja ich meinte dass dass es
eventuell leute gibt die sich extra
wegen dir quasi weil sie so dachten boa
der so cool und da manchmal
youtube-kanal damit den abonnieren kann
und so gibt es den leuten also hier gibt
und dass die eventuell sich dann extra
wegen der niederlage machte und events
oder gar nicht kennen deswegen weil sie
halt die leute noch seit relativ kurzen
dabei so nicht du mann ich bin diesmal
ich war mir ganz so eine tolle fahren
weil ich habe so vieles sieht
alles möglich ab strawberry seas und
alles mögliche zum einen typen hier ein
bisschen mir doch auch hier ist das
relikt relikt was kam relikt machen
da kannst du es mit ausbrüten und die
relikte sind unter anderem auch dafür da
ich habe mir seinen sohn jörg table
gebaut
da kannst du dann so brocken entziehen
source die kannst du mit relikten
reparieren und inzwischen komplett weg
ist weg und dieses ort ist richtig das
ist glaube ich so stark wie wo was bist
du denn vor einer wie ein diamant
schwert aber hat noch so ein richtig
geilen feuer flächen effekt und da muss
ich eigentlich unbedingt noch mehrere
legte finden
stimmt meine minions ihr solltet doch
wie immer wieder ein bisschen arbeiten
ist eine million sind irgendwie weg da
musst du z drücken dann drückst du an
zusammen minions und dann kann es sehr
genau
okay dass ich nicht dabei ja ich glaube
ich mache es wirklich erst mal eine
fassade hier so ein bisschen das soll
alles gerade ein bisschen schöner bei
mir aussehen
damit werde mich der minuten hier mal
besuchen kommt also jetzt nicht in
hamburg wieder wohnen sondern er wurde
sondern wenn ich hier wirklich dann mal
auf dieses verdammte portal geschützen
bekommen was du hast auch nicht noch
nicht nenne ich hab's ich weiß auch noch
ich habe mir einmal tutorial dazu
angeguckt aber ich hab's auch noch nicht
irgendwie komplett verstanden ist es
sieht auf jeden fall sehr lustig aus
weil man dann solche koordinaten
eingeben muss und ich hab gerade das
heißt ich kann ich die koordinaten von
meinem plumpsklo hier zu sein und du
kommst dann einfach mal dahin genau und
dann kann man runde zusammen zum
beispiel dass das ist eine sache die man
machen kann aber sie können ja auch ein
bisschen bisschen appetitliche sachen
machen wir dann zum beispiel
drachenkampf grabenkampf weit auch zum
tollen drachen besitzer bis dahin hast
du doch bestimmt eine nacht bestimmen
natürlich wer kommt vielleicht
vielleicht gibt ihr smith wie auch
eingehalten hat noch ein tor waffel
ach so wenig etwas merkwürdig wie
irgendwie verständlich denn wer ist das
volk einig dass ich den ich kenne wenn
projektes und so verfolge spielt hier
und dann
mensch sagt doch sturm oder stinke ratte
oder keine ahnung irgendwas hat der
zeitweilig ich wusste ja nicht dass du
diesen begriff nicht kennt so die leute
meinten dass hier noch irgendwo sachen
sind also bei bergmann natürlich merkt
oh ja ich glaub ich wieder gern potter
bekommt und wie viel jetzt 40
ich weiß aber auch nicht wie viele
bullen sich da bekomme das wäre so
traurig wenn ich einfach nur eine
munition musik als hier das heißt die
ganze zeit aber immer mal so wenn ich
ein keeper sehr tödlichen und ich hab
nur einen schuss er das wäre so traurig
man euch ist dieser permafrost und buch
ist herausgekommen dass natürlich sind
permafrost weil dann aus diesem perforce
hört sich an wie sein frostschutzmittel
bei autos könnte es auch sein aber fonds
ist allerdings aber auch wieder von den
anderen motto pack hier von diesem mit
den fossilien weil dann kann auch direkt
mit dna gemeinten bei mir ich hätte hier
fossilien übersehen
entweder bin ich blind waren ja weil so
auch mutlos ich schaffe es nicht creeper
zu töten
ich hatte richtig super taktik
entwickelt die macht jetzt auch wieder
ich fing an denen vorbei ok lag die
einmal und dann sehen ich bin ich quasi
aus diesen explosions rates von denen
raus und jetzt müsste ich in der krise
ja ok hatte das froyo doch ja du bist
jetzt live dabei wirklich mein erster
munition mache habe ich auch das heißt
leute mir was aus meinem daumen wenn
teils ihrer speisen ich habe schon
sortiersysteme da bin ich ja so stolz
drauf sondern ein bisschen habe ich
pflegte das nun ich habe mir kisten
gemacht so stelle ich hier unten bricht
das denn jetzt komm ich mache jetzt erst
mal platz für die patronen sasha 7 40
hast du schon ak ja läuft bei dir jetzt
habe ich hier immer okay ich schieße
damit jetzt einmal auf einem ottomotor
in china damit auf dem mob und dann
schaue ich mal was passiert was will ich
aber echt gespannt das wenn es jetzt
noch eine bundesländern mich aber ich so
traurig und boden zerstört ich kann den
ganzen hier soll die das werk auf am
besten auf irgendwas was nicht so weg
läuft
es läuft ja nicht weg ein mops und
zombies eigentlich ganz natürlich in
salzwasser ok-power ist das geil ich
habe 30 schuss das ist stark er die
waffen sind echt nahe ist aber viele
meinten auch dass die gar nicht so stark
sind
preis ok mit zwei schüssen hatte ich
damit jetzt unten mit dem dia schwer
brauchst du dafür drei okay er hat wurde
eigentlich der api oder sowie die heißen
verboten das sind auch die waffen die
die rüstung komplett ignorieren und zwei
bis drei schaden machen am herzen oder
so da müssen müssten eigentlich noch mal
mit den anderen bisschen sorgen um das
ei bewegt sich mal wieder gesehen
du meinst diesen genau wie er ab ich
weiß auch nicht genau dann häufig ganz
viele verschiedene davon
das ist schwerter und das sehen das
problem dass die rüstung ignorieren ist
das schön dass meine waffe funktioniert
und dass ich einfach 30 juni da schon
drin habe das freut mich gerade richtig
und honig verrühren schaden leute hast
du schön freut mich endlich was erreicht
endlich war sehr nach all meinen stuhl
schmalz dann erstmal weg vielleicht
nicht nicht wegschmeißen bald in ok aber
weißt du kannst du nicht einfach als
auch fremd sind
mein bett nämlich auch mit
ich muss jetzt einmal gucken das machen
wir so eine glasfront vor
so wird mega scheiße aussehen gleich das
jetzt hier nicht eingehen wo hab ich das
falsch geschrieben
ja ich glaube das wird heftig scheiße
aussehen ich glaub ich mache das jetzt
einfach ein bisschen anders
meine meine sachen werden nicht
aktualisiert wenn ich danach suche
inventory das doch enabled mode recipe
mode wenn du danach sucht naja also wenn
man du weißt auch wenn man es drückt und
dann irgendwie nach irgendeinem rezept
sucht und wenn ich jetzt hier zum
beispiel gern eingeben dann passiert
nichts dann sehe ich einfach immer nur
auf meine nervigen steam dynamos egal
das wird jetzt war ich wollte mir
eigentlich eine dubstep kann jetzt
einfach mal schnecken dubstep kann eine
tapst app kann was macht die die er die
die verschießt abdi macht also eine
ordentliche und luke oder so ich habe
die bei kev glaube ich mal gesehen ist
echt rebien eis aber so wirklich was
bringen tut sie auch nicht aber sie
macht es halt einfach ist ein nettes
feature überlegen ja genau advance jetix
da muss ich unbedingt jetzt hier unten
was freischaufeln ursachen für wieso du
brauchst du noch auf diamond 3uk jukebox
noten block und im letzten block
es geht doch das geht doch eigentlich
alles jedoch eigentlich aber das wäre
mir wieder viel zu viel arbeit
über dieses ganze zusammen kraftwerke
bock drauf gucke ich habe jetzt einfach
noch ein bisschen sand damit ich mit
glas machen kann hätte das ist eine gute
sache weißt du schön glas machen ist
tibet casual ja scheiß auf die
marschieren sind in mexiko lieber als
cool wirklich einfach meinen haushalt
kleinen bruder lebe damit nicht
glücklich wenn ich mir anders kräfte
weil das ganze auf die oldschool taktik
erst mal schön mit glasfront machen
die folgenden jahren wuchs um
juni ab 14 minuten bürger denn da muss
ich etwas nettes aufs nächste mal
verschieden mit egal gut mama warum denn
de ich wollte jetzt hier noch zehn
stunden drauf bleiben poker geht ein
worten ich hab kein bock mehr auf dich
weil du das ist lästig hatte sie steht
ein bisschen einen guten bands oft leute
heißt euch gefallen dann lass mir keine
bewertung dar
und ansonsten wünsche euch allen noch
ein gelähmter bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss